Hey Shankar Vidantam here. Thanks so much for listening to my podcast. I want to bring you a special hidden brain bonus episode for your weekend. One idea that intrigues me is the intersection of magic and psychology. It just so happens that longtime NPR producer Barry Gautamer is also a talented magician. So we teamed up to bring you a new segment we're going to call Magic Brain. I'm joined in the studio now by Melissa Melnicki. She's NPR's Talent Relations Manager, but the real reason she's here with me right now
嗨，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。非常感谢收听我的播客。我想为您在周末带来一期特别的“隐藏大脑”隐藏彩蛋节目。一个吸引我的想法是魔法和心理学的交集。碰巧的是，NPR长期制作人巴里·戈达默也是一位才华横溢的魔术师。因此我们联手为您带来一个新的环节，我们将其命名为“魔术大脑”。现在和我一起在录音室的是梅丽莎·梅尔尼基。她是NPR的人才关系经理，但她现在跟我在一起的真正原因是
is that she is an unsuspecting volunteer for an experiment that we're about to run on her. Melissa, hello. Hi, Shankar. How are you? I'm doing great. I'm not sure you're doing so great. And you might not be doing so great after I introduce you to our
因为她是我们将要对其实验的不知情的志愿者。梅丽莎，你好。嗨，尚卡尔。你好吗？我很好。我可不确定你是不是真的很好。在我把你介绍给我们之后，你可能就不会那么好了
Other visitor who is in the studio with us Barry Gordamer is a producer at Morning Edition But the reason he's here is that for 15 years Barry used to be a professional magician My stage name was the sort of amazing Barry Sort of amazing because I wasn't quite as good as the other magicians out there Sort of amazing because I wasn't quite as good as the other magicians out there. Barry, I think you're going to show Melissa something. I have a deck of cards in my hand, you can see they're all different. I'm going to spread them out in my hand's face down, please take a card. Any card.
另一位和我们一起在录音室的访客，巴里·戈尔达默是《早间新闻》的制作人，但他来这里的理由是，在过去的15年里，巴里曾是一名职业魔术师。我的艺名是“勉强惊艳的巴里”。“勉强惊艳”是因为我没有其他魔术师那么好。勉强惊艳是因为我没有其他魔术师那么好。巴里，我想你要给梅丽莎展示点东西。我手里有一副牌，你可以看到它们都是不同的。我要把它们面朝下在手里散开，请抽一张牌。随便哪张。
All right, and Melissa, careful now. Whatever you think you're going to pick first, don't pick that card and pick a completely different card. Or not. Any card. Okay. Here we go. Picking a card and not being manipulated. Alright.
好的，梅丽莎，现在小心点。不管你第一张想选什么，不要选那张牌，选一张完全不同的牌。或者不这样也行。随便哪张。好吧。我们开始吧。抽一张牌并且不被操纵。好吧。
So Melissa has extracted a card. You take a look at that card. I'm going to cut the deck in the middle. Please drop your card in there. Very good. It's better. It's better why you take a card. Alright. I'm going to do the same thing. I'm going to think of a card and I'm going to change the card that there. Very good. Charger, why don't you take a card? All right, I'm gonna do the same thing.
所以梅丽莎抽出一张牌。你看一眼那张牌。我要把牌从中间切开。请把你的牌放进去。很好。这样更好。为什么你抽一张牌会更好。好吧。我要做同样的事。我要想一张牌，然后我要换掉那张牌。很好。查杰，你为什么不抽一张牌？好的，我要做同样的事。
I'm gonna think of a card, and I'm gonna change the card that I pick right now and pick a different card. All righty. All right, I have looked at my card. Put it in the deck there, and... Okay, on the count of three, I would like for you to say the name of your card out loud.
我要想一张牌，然后把我刚才选的牌换掉，换一张不同的牌。好勒。好吧，我已经看我的牌了。把它放进牌堆里，然后……好的，数到三，我想请你大声说出你牌的名字。
One, two, three. Queen of Hearts. What? Are you kidding me? That, that, that, that blew my mind. How in the world did you do that Barry? As magicians like to say, very well. Clearly you did this very well. This is astonishing Barry. How did you know what I was gonna pick? This was an exercise in the manipulation of choice. I forced you to take the same card. You did not. I made a free choice to pick the card that I picked, Barry.
一，二，三。红桃Q。什么？你在开玩笑吗？这，这，这，这让我大开眼界。你到底是怎么做到的，巴里？正如魔术师常说的那样，做得很好。显然你做得非常好。这太惊人了，巴里。你怎么知道我会选哪张牌？这是对选择操纵的练习。我强迫你拿了同一张牌。你才没有。我做出了自由的选择，选了我选的那张牌，巴里。
Thank you for saying that. That's what I wanted you to think. But I, and the key to it. The key to it is you felt you had the freedom to do it. So this is fascinating because, of course, there's a whole body of social science research barrier that looks at this idea that you can actually nudge people into doing certain things while making them feel like they have freedom of choice.
谢谢你这么说。这就是我想让你想的。但关键在于，关键在于你觉得你有这样做的自由。所以这很迷人，因为当然，有一整套社会科学研究，巴里，着眼于这种观点，即你实际上可以引导人们做某些事情，同时让他们觉得自己拥有选择的自由。
And you know marketers have obviously been using these techniques on us for many years nudging us to buy this brand of soap rather than that brand of soap. But it gets really interesting when you're talking about manipulating really important life decisions. So researchers have found, for example, that you can influence whether people join a retirement savings plan when they start a new job. If you make the default option that you're automatically enrolled, unless you opt out, more people choose to participate in these savings plans compared to when the default option
你知道营销人员显然多年来一直在对我们使用这些技术，引导我们购买这个牌子的肥皂而不是那个牌子的肥皂。但当你谈论操纵真正重要的生活决策时，这就变得非常有趣了。例如，研究人员发现，当人们开始新工作时，你可以影响他们是否加入退休储蓄计划。如果你把默认选项设为自动加入，除非你选择退出，否则会有更多人选择参加这些储蓄计划，相比之下，如果默认选项
is you're not automatically signed up and you have to choose to sign up. People tend to feel like they have a free choice. When in fact, they actually tend to choose the default option no matter what that option is. The key point in that is people can't be aware initially that you are trying to influence them because that influences the choice. Now in this context, Shankar, you knew I was going to pull a trick, so you tried to influence what I was doing and influence what Melissa was doing. And funny enough,
是你没有自动注册，你必须选择注册。人们往往觉得自己有自由选择权。而事实上，无论该选项是什么，他们实际上往往会选择默认选项。其中的关键点是，人们一开始不能意识到你正试图影响他们，因为这会影响选择。现在在这种情况下，尚卡尔，你知道我要变个戏法，所以你试图影响我在做什么，并影响梅丽莎在做什么。有趣的是，
as a professional magician, I always found it easier to get someone to pick the card I wanted them to pick when they were trying to mess me up. So in other words, when they were trying to figure out what you were doing to manipulate them, you found it easier to manipulate them? Yes, I did and one of the reasons I think is because people are always laughing when this goes on and it's difficult to do critical thinking while you're laughing I think I'm gonna blame Melissa here because I think she did most of the laugh Yes, I did laugh right a bit. All right next time we will do the same trick without Melissa in the studio And I'm sure Barry Gordonimore you will not fool me. I'll take that challenge. Barry Gordimore I want to thank you for making some time for us today.
作为一名职业魔术师，我总是发现在别人试图搞砸我的时候，更容易让他们选出我想要的牌。换句话说，当他们试图弄清楚你在做什么来操纵他们时，你发现更容易操纵他们？是的，我确实这么觉得，原因之一我想是因为人们在这个过程中总是在笑，而在笑的时候很难进行批判性思考。我想我要在这里责怪梅丽莎，因为我觉得她笑得最多。是的，我确实笑了一会儿。好吧，下次我们将在没有梅丽莎在录音室的情况下做同样的把戏。我相信巴里·戈尔达默你不会愚弄我。我接受这个挑战。巴里·戈尔达默，我要感谢你今天为我们抽出时间。
Thank you. I enjoy getting in your head. Melissa Melnicki, thank you so much for coming in. Absolutely thanks for having me. This is Hidden Brain. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。我很享受进入你的大脑。梅丽莎·梅尔尼基，非常感谢你光临。绝对的，谢谢邀请。这是“隐藏大脑”。这个还没有这集的评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子来留下评论。